it looks so we could get an announcement
later on today
yes and it's a huge hugely historic
moment this um the exact opposite of
president putin of what president putin
wanted when he invaded ukraine he came
to this country saying that he wanted
less nato at his borders fearing that
this country ukraine
would seek to join nato which it has
been trying to
but as a result of the aggression here
in this country other european nations
are looking at their security situation
in a very different light now and no
more so than in finland a country that
has been neutral militarily since the
end of the second world war balancing
that relationship between the west and
between its eastern neighbor russia and
yet today we're expecting the finnish
president to give his verdict on whether
he believes his country should join nato
all indicators are that he is going to
say that it should and his decision
really is decisive it sets in course a
train of events which could then lead to
a formal application by finland to join
the alliance and that its neighbor
sweden is also expected to follow suit
and just one final point the finnish
president was speaking yesterday with
our prime minister boris johnson who
paid him a visit and in that
conversation he was he gave the reason
why finland is making this historic move
and blamed russia said to president
putin effectively just look in the
mirror what is happening here is because
of you
okay thank you